welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in the Batman details are slipping
out faster than the wet ground beneath
Robert Pattinson stuntman rector Matt
weeds just tweeted the first-ever looks
at his new Batmobile and unlike that
tactical tanks from recent iterations of
Batman this is a true muscle car with an
exposed back engine that's definitely
gonna vibrate the hell out of those bass
speakers in the theater there's kind of
this Mad Max funhouse instead of going
on kind of like an else world Batman not
something of our world but hypothetical
what-if thought experiment Batman which
is also pretty consistent with some of
the other creepy things were seen from
this movie these images also give us a
clearer look of Pattinson in the new bat
suit which is definitely more
form-fitting and silhouette minded than
his stunt version but same weaponized
gauntlets more on those in a bit I'm
gonna drop it earlier than normal boiler
warning here because even though people
who work on these film sets clearly have
no problem taking photos and blabbing
them all over the Internet
enough of you want to go into movies
blind as a bat to scare me into
obligatory spoiler warnings anyway B
latest in creepiest image to come out
from the film's production shows this
mystery man head wrapped up something
impaled between size and no more lies
written in red on the face the figure is
seated in this plush chair in dim
lamplight and we know this is definitely
from the movies production with real
numbers visible in the frame and it's
joined by a shot of a production
clapboard and additionally people are
claiming these images are being taken
down and where there's a cover-up
there's a legit leak and the first thing
to come into many people's minds with
tape head here might be the bandaged man
from the Batman hush storyline now hush
is one of the best Batman arcs that was
adapted into an animated film last year
met with mixed reviews comic is a Dark
War storyline I'll quickly summarize it
another spoiler Wernicke's want to read
hush yourself it definitely should it's
great if you're lazy you don't feel like
it's hush follows Batman as he and
Catwoman tried to figure out why so many
rogues gallery villains fluting Killer
Croc poison ivy Joker scarecrow a bunch
of um Thoreau acting out of character
for them they all seemed to be being
manipulated by someone behind the scenes
early on in the plot Batman fractures
his skull and he's operated on by a
childhood friend the surgeon dr. Thomas
Eliot around his investigation Batman's
movements are observed by a mysterious
bandaged man and the conspiracy begins
to mess with
Batman's mind he believes at what point
the bandaged man is the late Jason Todd
that all shape-shifting Clayface is
involved as well by the end of it all
Batman realizes that this bandaged man
trying to kill him is his buddy dr.
Elliott Thomas Elliott blames Bruce
Wayne and Bruce's father and we learned
that dr. Elliott was in cahoots with a
number of the rogues gallery with operas
to cure to various ailments most of all
Koontz with the Riddler who had been
suffering from cancer and the Riddler
invented the bandage Man identity and
named him hush and even though batman
ends up trapping the Riddler into
secrecy over his Bruce Wayne identity by
telling him that the riddle that
everyone knows the answer to is
worthless the plot has successfully left
Batman rattled because the final time he
chats with Catwoman she tries to stop
him from babbling by just saying hush
but the Batman freaks out he's like
why'd you say that were you a part of
this cuz Mary Jo there's more some part
of the code where say it's basically a
long con to cat block the bat it's
pretty great
now when the animated film version of
hush came out last year a number of
viewers were bummed over the changes to
condense this complex plot like making
Riddler himself hush and completely
omitting Jason totter Tim Drake so that
you know would better connect to DC's
current continuity but I have always
thought well maybe they left out certain
elements of the animated hush because
those were elements at the film's studio
and Matt Reeves intended to use for the
live-action Robert Pattinson film Batman
like we know this story will involve
several rogues gallery figures Selina
Kyle I thought a cup of hot the Riddler
whose name in this version is Edward
Nash - not Edward nygma there have been
hints that Tim Drake or Jason Todd could
be involved with a plot with casting
notices for circus performers and set
signs for orphanages hey we got a bunch
of kids with deaf parents yet and Peter
Sarsgaard is playing Gil - Gotham
district attorney who has gotta be
playing a bigger role in this movie it's
ours guards very good at playing ability
now we had this fella tape head well I
really hope that the Matt Reeves Batman
film incorporates some elements from
hush like a noir mystery that constantly
keeps Batman guessing a romance with
Catwoman that leaves Batman scarred
perhaps even Hutch as the villainous
figure but I don't think this guy tape
head is hush he's got that spike in the
words there's clearly more going on here
he is a victim of someone and I'm
betting that whatever jamoke took this
photo was probably like
getting really good shot of this movie
and there's no big deal it's not like
actor space or anything and then let's
send it off and oh I'm fired look it's
hard to know what's certainty any of
this stuff just like it's kind of tough
to know if someone has a wallet in their
front pocket because it's so sleek and
discreet which by the way thanks to the
ridge for sponsoring this episode the
ridge makes everyday goods for the
standard you don't see everyday they
streamline their life by turning the
things you carry like backpacks and
chargers and wallets into tools for a
better living their flagship product is
the ridge wallet it was launched on
Kickstarter in 2013 and now sits in the
front pockets of over half a million men
and women just like many of my theories
my wallets used to be full of full lots
of stuff but no more see this is their
aluminum wallet in the raw color they
have other colors including some very
flashy Tiki designs it's light and it's
strong and it has a cool industrial chic
vibe the ribbed is a minimal front
pocket wallet is designed to streamline
what you carry every day it has 30,000
five-star reviews and is a better way to
carry your cash and cards there's a
lifetime warranty if you love it free
returns if you don't love it but you're
gonna love it it comes in titanium
carbon fire aluminum and over a dozen
different styles and colors they also
have these great backpacks and travel
bags they got RFID blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries love
this thing get 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to rigid comm slash new rock stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and use a code at new rockstars find the
link in the description below but let's
take a closer look at tape head no CSI
new rockstars tells me that the victim
was suffocated poked for good measure
and then left in Bruce Wayne's mansion
in order to force him to reveal himself
cork does the bat gadget ah more than
anything this victim tells us a lot
about this movies tone we are looking at
a very dark crime story with a high body
count and probably some gruesome deaths
maybe in the vein of seven or Silence of
the Lambs and hey maybe r-rated Warner
seems very open r-rated takes on their
DC characters after Joker and birds of
prey and an r-rated Batman might be
exactly what we need to have a good
Batman movie again
and a murder victim with a message like
this strikes the same notes for me as
they murdered vigilantes from the dark
night the one that the Joker left with a
card reading will the real Batman please
stand up as a way to pressure Bruce to
come forward and while we're on the
subject of duplicate Batman's I should
also point out the possibility that that
bulky Batman suit that we saw in set
photos and videos could be a secondary
Batman figure like a copycat Batman a
copy of them going around causing
trouble to make people think he's the
real guy like that spike impaling tape
head could be one of the projectiles we
saw on that Batman's gauntlet things
look deadly I'm just surprised that the
real Batman would equip himself with
easily accessible deadly weapons in
again I guess a Batarang aimed at
someone's I would kill I would just
leave you with the question of who this
figure is under the tape I'm wondering
if it is someone of significance maybe
like SARS guards characters a district
attorney or John Turturro as carmine
Falcone maybe even Jason Todd or Tim
Drake are we looking at a dead Robin
here and for our thoughts on a lot of
stuff be sure to join our official
discord or new Rockstar staff and
followers of this channel have been
mixing it up with some fascinating nerdy
conversations join the discord by
becoming a patron today at patreon.com
slash new rock stars who do you think
this is comment down below and follow me
on Instagram or Twitter I da boss follow
new rock stars and subscribe to new rock
stars here on YouTube for Brick dads of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]